verkürzung der korona quarantäne reise
rückkehrer aus risikogebieten sollen
innerhalb der eu nur noch zehn tage
isoliert werden
mit dem zug durch die schweizer alpen
nach 14 jahren bauzeit wird der chenery
basis tunnel nördlich von lugano
feierlich eröffnet drohende
umweltkatastrophe im indischen ozean vor
der küste von sri lanka brennt ein
tanker mit hunderttausenden tonnen öl an
bord
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten am freitag mit sport und
norbert lehmann erfurt
bisher hatte jedes land in europa seine
eigenen corona bestimmungen für
geschäftsreisende und urlauber
verwirrend jetzt haben sich die
gesundheitsminister der eu auf eine
einheitliche quarantäne regelung
verständigt
so galt in deutschland bislang eine
14-tägige quarantäne für reise
rückkehrer aus risikogebieten
nun soll sie europaweit auf zehn tage
verkürzt werden
thomas reichert berichtet die großen
ferien enden für viele mit einer großen
frage ist dass urlaub sind zwischen zum
risiko land geworden drohen zwei wochen
quarantäne
die eu gesundheitsminister haben sich
heute auf einheitliche regeln geeinigt
für deutschland bedeutet dass rückkehrer
aus risikogebieten müssen bald kürzer in
quarantäne
dabei konnten wir uns darauf einigen
dass nach reisen aus risikogebieten eine
generelle quarantäne von mindestens 10
tage angezeigte ist etwas umstritten ist
die frage ob es möglich sein soll durch
ein negatives testergebnis nach fünf
tagen auch europaweit im gemeinsamen
ansatz dann die quarantäne zu verkürzen
die erleichterung kommt in einer zeit da
die infektionszahlen zumindest leicht
sinken 1180 menschen haben sich im
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
täglich neu infiziert zuvor waren es
1200 der virologie christian drosten
macht noch einen anderen vorschlag
lernen corona virus erkrankt es könnte
seiner ansicht nach ebenfalls kürzer als
bislang isoliert werden
auf twitter schreibt er mein vorschlag
ist reduktion der isolierung zeit wenn
man cluster des ganzes isoliert dann
kurz zum beispiel fünf tage und mit frei
testung auf rest infektiosität der
vorschlag bekam umgehend unterstützung
aus der politik
die verkürzung der quarantänezeit wäre
unbedingt sinnvoll es haben sich also in
neuen studien immer wieder die
ergebnisse bestätigt dass nach fünf
tagen im prinzip die ansteckung vorbei
ist also diejenigen die symptome haben
und fünf tagen kann
sind in der regel nicht mehr anstecken
gesundheitsminister sparen aber lehnt
die idee ab er sehe dafür derzeit keine
notwendigkeit die linke sucht nach einer
neuen doppelspitze für den bundesvorsitz
nun haben janine wissler und susanne
hennig will sie ihren hut in den ring
geworfen
whistler ist derzeit chefin der
linksfraktion im hessischen landtag
wenn ich will so leitet die fraktionen
in thüringen
sie wurde bundesweit für ihre wütende
geste gegen fdp-politiker kemmerich
bekannt die bisherigen
bundesvorsitzenden kipping und riexinger
treten nach acht jahren nicht wieder an
noch zwei monate bis zur präsidentenwahl
in den usa und der herausforderer beiden
führt in den umfragen immer noch
deutlich wenn auch der abstand schon
größer war die auftritte der
kontrahenten könnten unterschiedlicher
kaum sein
joe biden besuchte eine afro
amerikanische gemeinde in komischer der
stadt in der polizisten einen schwarzen
in den rücken geschossen hatten
präsident trump ließ sich derweil in
pennsylvania von teils dicht gedrängten
anhängern feiern und machte sich darüber
lustig dass sein kontrahent regelmäßig
einen mundschutz trägt britta jäger joe
biden bietet in einer kirche in kinos
vor der gemeinde gibt er sich als
zuhörer als kümmerer und wählt selbst
sanfte worte anders als präsident trump
hatte er zuvor mit jacob lake gesprochen
dem polizisten sieben mal in den rücken
geschossen hatten
die begegnung war sehr ermutigend und
bevor wir überhaupt über die dinge reden
konnten die uns wichtig sind hatte er
sie bereits angesprochen
es ging nicht nur um trost er hatte ein
echtes anliegen den kampf gegen die tief
verwurzelte ungleichheit im land
verspricht beiden zur chefsache zu
machen sollte er ins weiße haus
einziehen
er will das kontrastprogramm zu donald
trump wir erreichen nun endlich den
punkt an dem wir uns mit der erbse
unseres landes beschäftigen mit der 400
jahre alten erbsünde der sklaverei und
ihrer überreste beiden führt in den
umfragen auch in umkämpften
bundesstaaten fake news behauptet der us
präsident vor anhängern in pennsylvania
seine strategie ist nach wie vor der
aggressive konter kurs beiden wird
niemals eure jobs und familien
beschützen können er ist eine marionette
der sozialistischen marxisten in den
umfragen und die echten umfragen haben
nur wir liegen wir überall vorn doch ein
zeitungsbericht könnte ihm nun probleme
bereiten gefangenen oder getöteter
us-soldaten soll tram wiederholt
abschätzig als verlierer oder trottel
bezeichnet haben sagen mitglieder aus
seinem engeren kreis der präsident wies
die vorwürfe entschieden zurück auch das
sei alles fake nicht ja da müssen wir
noch mal bei unserem amerika
korrespondenten elmar theveßen
nachfragen immer wie wird diese
bemerkung trumps im land denn nun
aufgenommen ja es gibt heftige
reaktionen empörter eltern von
gefallenen us-soldaten auch ehemalige
generäle melden sich zu wort werfen dem
präsidenten vor er sei kein patriot
einige fordern dazu auf joe biden zu
wählen das ganze geht auf einen vorfall
aus dem jahr 2018 zurück das soll der
us-präsident sich geweigert haben in
frankreich an den amerikanischen
soldatenfriedhof aus dem zweiten
weltkrieg zu besuchen
er habe die us gefallenen eben als
verlierer und trottel bezeichnet das
beweist der präsident die eben massiv
zurück auch einige seiner berater aber
mehrere us-medien haben mittlerweile aus
weiteren quellen bestätigt dass die
worte damals so gefallen sein sollen
das passt auch ein stück weit zu der
wortwahl die doch mit donald trump
benutzt hat in der vergangenheit er hat
den republikanischen senator john mccain
der mittlerweile verstorben ist der ein
kriegsheld ist weil er in
kriegsgefangenschaft in vietnam war auch
als verlierer bezeichnet sein
generalstab auch als verlierer und
trottel
das ist eindeutig belegt er verliert
momentan an zustimmung innerhalb des
militärs das zeigen meinungsumfragen das
eine ganz wichtige wählergruppe für ihn
und wenn jetzt ein augenzeuge von damals
ein hochrangiger militär beispielsweise
öffentlich noch einmal bestätigen würde
dass diese geschichte wahr ist dann
könnte ihm das erhebliche
schwierigkeiten bereiten für die wahl am
dritten november
vielen dank matti wissen und nun schauen
wir in ein land das so viele coroner
neuinfektionen an einem tag zu
verkraften hat wie noch nie israel zählt
2991 neue fälle deutlich mehr als
deutschland bei nur rund neun millionen
einwohnern mit strengen auflagen für die
bürger hatte das land im frühjahr die
infektion erfolgreich eingedämmt
doch mit den lockerungen im mai kam
corona mit macht zurück
jetzt stehen die israelis vor neuen
einschränkungen aus tel aviv michael
bewerunge nur die maske verdeckt die
sorgenvolle miene von moshe morgenstern
gesundheits bürgermeister von bewag die
stadt am rande von tel aviv gehört zu
den zentren der ultraorthodoxen hier
sind die korona zahlen besonders hoch
die synagoge ist geschlossen die
menschen beten draußen mit maske
morgenstern glaubt alles richtig zu
machen
ich kenne keine stadt die sich so an die
regeln hält andererseits mache ich mir
sehr sehr große sorgen unsere fallzahlen
steigen die ganze zeit und gehören zu
den höchsten im land in israels
ampelsystem gehört nebra daher zu den
stätten der roten zone über die ab
montag erneut an lockdown verhängt
werden könnte trotz engmaschiger
überwachung im krisenzentrum der stadt
steigen die zahlen warum gerade hier
erklärt morgenstern so viele orthodoxe
leben in sozial schwachen verhältnissen
mit wenig geld nicht selten 15 bis 20
menschen in einer winzigen wohnung mit
nur einer dusche und einer toilette wird
einer unbemerkt krank steckte alle
anderen an die lage beraten
doch auch in prag und anderen gemeinden
verweigern rabbis die kooperation und
auch die arabische bevölkerung hält sich
nicht immer an die hygieneregeln große
hochzeiten finden statt den corona
beauftragten bringt das zu einem
dramatischen appell bitte keine
hochzeiten mehr keine massenaufläufe und
schon gar keine illegalen
sammlungen und keine missachtung der
regel mehr in irgend einem restaurant
oder sonstwo sollten erneute
ausgangssperren in den roten zone nicht
helfen warnt kam so sei der komplette
locker und unausweichlich dann für ganz
israel mit der bahn einfach unter den
schweizer alpen durch als letztes
puzzlestück in diesem ehrgeizigen plan
wurde heute der chenery basis tunnel im
tessin eröffnet 15,4 kilometer führt er
nördlich von lugano durch den fels und
verlängert die route die von norden her
durch den gotthard basistunnel kommt das
herzstück eines gesamteuropäischen
projekt bei dem es insgesamt aber noch
hakt eva schiller
es geht ohne kostenexplosion und fast im
zeitplan und wie stolz die schweizer auf
das größte bauprojekt ihrer geschichte
sind ist der eröffnungsfeier des general
bahntunnels anzumerken
die hochgeschwindigkeits trasse quer
durch die alpen die sogenannte nähert
bereit für den güterverkehr
die nähert ist unser jahrhundert wird
sie macht uns stolz und sie macht unser
land stark der schweizer teil herzstück
einer lang geplanten verbindung zwischen
der see und dem süden
aber es hakt und zwar beim deutschen
abschnitt im rheintal vor 24 jahren
geplant aber zum leidwesen der
logistikbranche lange noch nicht fertig
straßen sind völlig überlastet wir
wollen güter auf die schiene verlagern
dadurch dass der deutsche strecken teil
jetzt nicht fertig ist ist ein bruch im
system und so können gütern nicht über
die gesamte strecke gefahren werden was
für die logistik von starkem nachteil
ist
im rheintal wehrten sich erst die
anwohner dann folgt umplanung auf
umplanung 2017 dann eine panne nahe ras
statt auf europas wichtigster
verkehrsachse sacken die gleise ab weil
darunter gebohrt wird erklärungsversuche
schuld ist hier sicherlich eine lange
kette von fehlentscheidungen meines
erachtens sind bei der deutschen bahn
und in der bundesregierung die
prioritäten falsch gesetzt worden
das ist aus meiner sicht das wichtigste
aus projekt in deutschland es ist aber
häufig über viele jahre nachrangig
behandelt worden
jetzt nimmt man es ernster aber man hat
halt viele jahre um nicht zu sagen
jahrzehnte verloren
in der schweiz haben die bewohner erst
abgestimmt dann wurde gesprengt und
gebaut nach deutschland blicken die
verantwortlichen mit einer mischung aus
spott und ärger der ausbau der gleise
wird auf deutscher seite noch mindestens
bis 2035 dauern
die erneuerung der katholischen kirche
auf dem synodalen weg kam heute einen
schritt weiter corona bedingt allerdings
nur als zwischenetappe
statt der geplanten großen synodale
versammlung mit mehr als 200 teilnehmern
gab es fünf kleinere regionalkonferenzen
dabei standen die rufe nach mehr
beteiligung von frauen im mittelpunkt
aus frankfurt berichtet in den clips den
werden
schon vor der tür machen frauen klar
trotz corona soll die katholische kirche
sich erneuern den begonnenen sogenannten
synodalen weg weitergehen die rolle der
frau ist ein zentrales thema hierfür
daniela ordowski die in der
arbeitsgruppe zur position von frauen
mitarbeitet ist das fernziel klar ich
glaube es gibt einfach keine guten
argumente auch keine theologisch guten
argumente die frauen aus der kirche
ausschließen und die tatsächliche
diskriminierung rechtfertigen die
momentan stattfindet der vorsitzende der
bischofskonferenz zeigt sich
optimistisch dass es voran gehen wird
auch in der frauenfrage die ungeduld
wächst und die frauenfrage wird die
entscheidende zukunftsfrage der kirche
in unserem land ich glaube aber weltweit
sein
es sind nur etwa 50 im saal laien neben
bischöfen wegen des infektionsrisikos
wird an fünf verschiedenen orten
diskutiert es sind intensive gespräche
beim thema sexualität steht etwa die
frage im raum kann die katholische
kirche anerkennen dass die nicht nur der
fortpflanzung dient und wenn es so ist
dann kommen viele konsequenzen daraus
zum beispiel dass kondome erlaubt werden
können dass die pille erlaubt werden
können und am ende auch die frage der
homosexualität hängt damit zusammen
als dämpfer empfinden viele hier aber
eine instruktion die kürzlich aus rom
kam und laien die alleinige leitung
einer gemeinde verbietet auch in
deutschland können sich nicht alle
bischöfe für die reformvorstellungen
begeistern
es bleibt ein schwieriger weg sri lanker
droht eine umweltkatastrophe
dort ist ein feuer auf einem voll
beladenen öltanker ausgebrochen nach
einer explosion im maschinenraum war der
frachter gestern rund 70 kilometer vor
der ostküste des landes havariert
seitdem steht er in flammen und schreibt
weiter auf die insel zu mit insgesamt
rund 270.000 tonnen öl an bord zum
vergleich die exxon valdez verlor bei
ihrer havarie 1989 vor alaska
nur rund ein siebtel dieser menge normen
odenthal das längste stück der reise war
schon geschafft von kuwait nach indien
doch dann die explosion im maschinenraum
jetzt brennt die new diamond vor der
ostküste sri lankas und die
rettungskräfte bekommen die lage nicht
unter kontrolle
immerhin es gebe kein leck der rumpf sei
weiter dicht heißt es und das feuer hat
die ladung nicht erreicht noch nicht
denn das wäre der gau
der schaden könnte immens seien an bord
des schiffes sind etwa 260.000 tonnen
rohöl dazu kommt noch der
dieseltreibstoff das bedeutet also große
gefahr für sri lanka und natürlich
sollte es an bord eine explosion geben
wird
alles noch viel schlimmer ein seemann
wird vermisst für ihn gibt es wohl kaum
hoffnungen die übrigen 22 crewmitglieder
sind gerettet jetzt ist niemand mehr an
bord
na ja immer näher richtung küste treibt
es den juden und nun versuchen sie den
tanker weiter rauszuziehen auf dem
wasser und aus der luft wird gelöscht
indien unterstützt die marine sri lankas
denn für die ganze region steht viel auf
dem spiel ein umwelt paradies lebensraum
für seltene wale haie schildkröten ist
von der katastrophe bedroht
im fall der fünf getöteten kinder in
solingen gibt es erste
ermittlungsergebnisse
wie die staatsanwaltschaft mitteilte
wurden die drei mädchen und zwei jungen
vermutlich erstickt tatverdächtig ist
weiter die 27 jahre alte mutter gegen
sie hat ein richter nun haftbefehl
erlassen
nina niebergall und ralph goldmann
berichten
trauer und fassungslosigkeit vor dem
haus in solingen hassel heide in dem das
schreckliche verbrechen geschah fünf
kinder sind tot zwischen anderthalb und
acht jahren die 27-jährige mutter wird
verdächtigt sie getötet zu haben
die ermittler sprechen von emotionaler
überforderung
wir können zum motiv nur mutmaßen dass
das ursprüngliche der ursprüngliche
grund aus der zerrütteten ehe
hervorgegangen ist das ehepaar lebt seit
einem jahr in trennung die polizei fand
die kinder am vortag tot in ihren betten
sie wiesen keine anzeichen stumpfer
gewalt auf die daraufhin heute
durchgeführten obduktionen der getöteten
kinder
er gab bei allen fünf kindern hinweise
auf einen ersticken so wie auch hinweise
auf ein sedieren nach der tat ist die
mutter mit ihrem sechsten kind einem
elfjährigen jungen an den düsseldorfer
hauptbahnhof gefahren
dort hat sie sich vor einen zug geworfen
überlebte aber
der junge blieb unverletzt laut
jugendamt gab es keine erkenntnisse dass
die kinder gefährdet gewesen sein
ob es dennoch warnzeichen hilferufe gab
das werden die ermittler noch klären
müssen deutschland erlebt dann corona
einen camping boom seit dem frühjahr
erfreut sich die branche an immer mehr
interessenten besonders hoch im kurs
stehen wohnmobile die neuzulassungen
verdoppelten sich im vergleich zum juli
des vergangenen jahres auf knapp 11.000
fahrzeuge was es in diesem bereich neues
gibt das zeigt der caravan salon in
düsseldorf eine messe trotz corona mit
publikum peter böhme berichtet tage der
offenen türen in düsseldorf frischluft
für die messehallen kroner bedingt nur
20.000 erlaubte besucher pro tag im
letzten jahr kamen doppelt so viele aber
dafür dürfen sie eine messe machen die
erste große mit publikum seit monaten
und virtuell sollte die nicht sein
die menschen wollen ja das fahrzeug
wirklich nicht nur sehen sondern
ertasten im wahrsten sinne das kann man
nur sehr sehr begrenzt digital abbilden
vor allem wohnmobile boomen im fokus
besonders kastenwagen die von der länge
her auch für den alltag einsetzbar sind
die gibt's auch mit hochbett für
familien
die branche ist ein corona gewinner
deutschland war schon immer ein
wunderbares reiseland und aufgrund der
grenzschließungen ganz zu beginn hat man
natürlich keine andere möglichkeiten
gehabt und so haben viele menschen
einfach deutschland vielleicht auch von
einer neuen seite kennen gelernt aber
nicht jeder auf der messe fährt schon im
eigenen häuschen durch die gegend denn
damals schon gemacht ja gut aber wir
wollen mal irgendwann sohn zum caravan
kaufen vielleicht mal ein bisschen durch
euro partikeln oder wie außerdem
brauchen wir noch ein paar jahre zu
arbeiten das ist die überlegung auch
unsere freizeit dann entsprechend so zu
gestalten alles eine frage des preises
diesen mini wohnwagen etwa gibt es ab
11.000 euro mit weniger komfort für eine
flexible zielgruppe
das sind junge leute die
unterschiedliche sachen damit machen
ob nun der max und die ann kathrin
heiraten und das fahrzeug wird als hotel
ersatz genutzt oder aufs konzert nach
wacken oder aber für spontan touren
luxus gibt es auch vielleicht nichts für
die altstadt von avignon
dafür nimmt man den kleinwagen aus der
garage
drinnen lässt sich sehr gut aushalten
das ganze für 660.000 euro so viel
kostet diese camping welt glücklich und
jetzt zum sport und zum fußball arbeit
das war ja gestern ein etwas
unglücklicher start dieses last minute
tor der spanier zum 1 2 1 einfach nur
ärgerlich verärgert ist bundestrainer
joachim löw aber besonders wegen der
hohen körperlichen belastung für die
mannschaft durch den doch sehr üppigen
spielplan joachim löw stört der volle
terminkalender
nach dem 1 1 gegen spanien kritisierte
er dass in kürzester zeit noch sieben
spiele an steht der terminkalender ist
wahnsinnig vorab schon immer gesagt man
müsse aufpassen ist die gesundheit der
spieler steht über allem
der bundestrainer ärgert sich auch
darüber dass sind der nächstens liegt
nur drei statt fünf wechsel erlaubt sind
und übt scharfe kritik an der uefa
gerade jetzt gerade jetzt hat man es
gebraucht weil die spieler jetzt eben
dieses mammut bekommen haben und bisher
das hin gemacht weil einige sind echt
irgendwie auf dem zahnfleisch natürlich
gelaufen es gab einige ansätze mit denen
löw zufrieden sein konnte verzichten
muss er beim nächsten spiel auf herz der
abgereist ist und nach dem medizincheck
einen vertrag beim fc chelsea
unterschreiben wird
weltfußballer lionel messi bleibt nun
doch beim fc barcelona das hat er heute
in einem interview gesagt er wolle
seinen vertrag bei barca bis sommer
nächsten jahres erfüllen zur formel 1
vor dem großen preis von italien in
monza am sonntag hat sebastian vettel
wieder einmal enttäuscht im zweiten
freien training kommt der heppenheimer
nach einem dreher nicht über platz 12
hinaus ganz vorne dagegen die mercedes
piloten hamilton und bottas ein guter
tag für den deutschen radsport bei der
tour de france emanuel buchmann acht
plätze gut und das team bohrer hans
kröll fährt ins grüne trikot peter sagan
übernimmt das trikot des besten
sprinters dabei lief heute nicht alles
wie geplant
die hoffnung von sagan auf den tagessieg
bei dieser siebten etappe in labor macht
dieser rempler auf der zielgeraden
zunichte den etappensieg holt sich der
belgier bart van aart emanuel buchmann
ist in der spitzengruppe dabei und
verbessert sich im gesamtklassement
dadurch auf platz zwölf nicht richtig
geil das zusehen wie man da von vorne
gefahren sind nach dem session tage
nicht so lief im team haben jetzt ja
auch fast gereicht hat pech gehabt
oder eine gesamtheit noch einmal wissen
zeit gut gemacht auf einen kaffee und
das auf jeden fall richtig guter tag für
uns im gelben trikot fährt weiter der
brite am morgen wird es besonders hart
für die radprofis die ersten beiden
pyrenäen-etappen danken und noch zum
wochenend wetter das wird im norden kühl
und im süden bei was sie genau erwartet
erfahren sie gleich von özden terli
damit sind wir am ende der sendung und
danken für ihr interesse
marietta slomka erwartet sie um 10 zum
heute journal
und hier übernimmt morgen barbara
hahlweg ein schönes wochenende wünschen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter eine neue
kaltfront kündigt sich an und die kommt
von westen aufgezogen und bringt regen
dieser regen überquert uns morgen im
tagesverlauf nach osten und dahinter
fließt kühlere luft ein
in der nacht ist der regen schon im
westen und land verlagert sich langsam
nach osten im süden dagegen ist es
trocken und die temperaturen sinken in
der norddeutschen tiefebene bis auf 11
grad ab ansonsten sind es 12 bis 14 grad
im süden auch teils 14
an der neiße am mildesten mit 16 grad
morgen dann schieben sich die schauer
worten weiter in den osten von westen
her lockert es schon wieder auf an der
nordsee gibt es kräftigen westwind teils
stürmisch im süden da zeigt sich die
sonne häufiger und es ist trocken
temperaturen erreichen dort 24 bis 28
grad kühler ist es im norden hier spürt
man schon die kältere luft 16 grad sind
es in schleswig holstein die kommenden
tage bringen noch schauer vor allem am
sonntag im norden ansonsten auch im
süden dazwischen trocken 15 bis 20 grad
also deutlich kühler und ab montag wird
es langsam wärmer dienstag wieder bis 25
grad
ein schöner abend